sehr geehrter herr präsident frau
bundeskanzlerin sehr geehrte damen und
herren das unwürdige schauspiel geht in
die nächste runde
eine von der verfassung nicht
vorgesehene kugelrunde beschließt im
hinterzimmer weitreichende eingriffe in
das leben und in die freiheit der bürger
die kanzlerin liegt vorher fest was
dabei herauskommen soll
die ministerpräsidenten betreiben im
vorfeld pr in eigener sache spielen
opposition letztlich fügen sie sich doch
das parlament jedoch die stimme des
souveräns darf hinterher noch ein wenig
darüber debattieren wie heute ist aber
in die entscheidung nicht eingebunden
was für eine panische inszenierung was
für eine dreiste zurschaustellung von
arroganz der macht sehr geehrte damen
und herren
und was für eine offene missachtung der
bürger die unter ihren einsamen
beschlüssen leiden wo mit denen sie
umspringen wie mit untertanen über deren
leben rechte schicksale sie nach
belieben verfügen zu können glauben was
die bundesregierung hier betreibt ist
verfassungswidrig
sie spielen mit der zukunft unserer
kinder
es ist nicht das virus oder die pandemie
die einer ganzen generation von schülern
und kindern die bildungschancen raub es
ist ihre falsche politik die nur verbot
und zwar zu kennen scheint die jungen
und älteren menschen familien und
berufstätigen selbstständigen
unternehmern wertvolle lebenszeit nimmt
sie in depression einsamkeit und in den
ruin treibt
drei monate wellenbrecher lockdown und
sie wollen noch einmal ein
dranhängen die kollateralschäden ihrer
methode von einsperren und dicht machen
wachsen ins unermessliche die deutsche
herzstiftung befürchtet einen massiven
anstieg von hertz toten weil
eingeschüchterte patienten nicht zum
arzt gehen
ausgebliebene vorsorgeuntersuchungen
werden auch die zahl der krebstoten
ansteigen lassen
auch auf dem arbeitsmarkt hinterlässt
diesellok darum politik eine spur der
verwüstung
eine halbe million neue arbeitslose
millionen kurzarbeiter 175000
unternehmer und selbständige die vor der
insolvenz stehen gastronome und
gewerbetreibende den lebenswerk
zerbricht
einzelhändler die ihre letzten reserven
längst verbraucht haben die auf bergen
von unverkaufte ware und schulden sitzen
aber von den großspurig angekündigten
hilfen noch immer nichts gesehen haben
das haben sie eben zugegeben ich frage
mich wollen sie den mittelstand das
rückgrat unseres wohlstands vernichten
wollen sie uns auf den stand eines
entwicklungslandes bringen dann sagen
sie es bitte ganz offen die leute wollen
das wissen woran sie sind wenn sie das
nächste mal zur wahl gehen sehr geehrte
damen und herren und sie klammern sich
an den wirtschafts und
verfassungsfeindlichen lockdown als gäbe
es keine intelligenten alternativen und
stadt den bürgern eine verlässliche
perspektive für die rückkehr zur
normalität zu bieten
verändern sie laufen willkürlich die
parameter verdopplung seit er wird
sieben tage incidents die für die 200er
inzidenz beschlossenen maßnahmen einfach
bis zu einem incidents wert von 35
fortzuführen ist ein erneuter
rechtsbruch das muss man ganz klar sagen
die schnell impfung großer teile der
bevölkerung diese ebenfalls zur
zielgröße erklärt haben hat ihre
regierung grandios versiebt weil sie die
zuständigkeit unterbrechung das
subsidiaritätsprinzip nach brüssel
delegiert haben und jetzt sind es neu
aufgetretene virus varianten
sie sagen mutanten das klingt bedrohlich
diaz lockdown rechtfertigung herhalten
müssen
die bürger haben dieses hin und her ich
muss es ihnen ganz klar sagen diese
hinhaltepolitik satt sie wollen nicht
länger für politikversagen in geiselhaft
genommen werden
sie fühlen sich mit recht für dumm
verkauft wenn sie erfahren dass die
innenminister schon vor dem ersten job
bei willfährigen wissenschaftler
möglichst dramatische szenarien
angefordert hat um harte einschränkungen
einfordern zu können oder wenn er
rauskommt dass das kanzleramt
mit hastig hingeworfenen bestellten
gefälligkeitsgutachten auch schnelle und
lang schulschließung hingewirkt hat wo
sie ihre günstlinge hinsetzen um es mal
ganz klar zu sagen da versagen diese
herr altmaier bei der entschädigung der
von zwang schließung betroffenen
gewerbetreibenden und frau von der leyen
bei der organisation der impfstoff
beschaffung das ist schon atemberaubend
sich hinzustellen und zu behaupten es
sei im großen und ganzen nichts schief
gelaufen und die bundesregierung tue ihr
bestes
ich will mir gar nicht vorstellen was
alles passiert sein muss dass sie
endlich mal fehler eingestehen unfassbar
die korona politik in unserem land muss
grundlegend neu ausgerichtet werden
wir brauchen den raschen und
verbindlichen ausstieg aus dem lot
der weg dorthin muss öffentlich und
unter einbeziehung des parlaments
beraten werden
dafür muss ohne diffamierung und
ausgrenzung die gesamte bandbreite der
fachlichen und wissenschaftlichen
expertise gehört werden
ziel muss sein die hochbetagten und vor
erkranken in öffentlichen einrichtungen
besonders zu schützen
allen anderen gefährdeten
selbstverantwortlichen eigenschutz zu
ermöglichen genügend impfstoff für alle
impfwilligen hin bereitzustellen das
gesundheitssystem so zu stärken dass es
mit den vermeintlichen erkrankung fertig
wird und allen bürgern ein möglichst
normales leben zu ermöglichen
dafür zahlen sie nämlich steuern und
dafür zahlen sie auch in das
sozialversicherungssystem an die
grundrechte müssen wieder in kraft
gesetzt werden
sie werden von der verfassung garantiert
und nicht von der regierung zugeteilt
eine einschränkung ist
begründungspflicht ich und nicht ihre
wiederherstellung sehr geehrte da haben
uns
und das ist natürlich nicht so leicht
wie drohen verbieten und geld verteilen
im dauer ausnahmezustand aber genau
dafür sind sie gewählt worden
kehren sie also zurück zu einer
verfassungsgemäßen politik kinder